upper Moon 4 huntengu is the trickiest
most psychotic and arguably the most
dangerous demon in all of Demon Slayer
and by the end of this video you will
know all about his unique blood demon
art all seven of his different demon
forms and how he went from a thief and
serial killer to the fifth most powerful
demon in the world this video will give
you not only all the relevant
information from the manga but also
additional information from the Demon
Slayer extra material some of which has
never been officially translated into
English so be sure to keep watching
until the very end
when we first see him during the big
meeting of the upper moons upper Rank 4
huntengu gives off the impression of a
Meek timid and superstitious old man
although he certainly looks creepy and
unsettling he doesn't look very
threatening especially when compared to
the other upper moons when akasa dolma
and kokushibo engage in their violent
exchanges hunting who looks terrified
and he also seems absolutely horrified
by the fact that the upper moons have
displeased their Master muzon based on
huntengu's behavior during the meeting
it would be easy to conclude that he's
one of the weakest and most useless
demons that we've ever encountered in
the series and yet we know that he is
upper Moon Four someone who is stronger
than both gyutaro and gyoko how is that
even possible well that is the
paradoxical Brilliance of Han tengu's
character so let's break it down if you
guys enjoy our Demon Slayer content then
you want us to keep it going leave a
quick like and comment right now to help
us with that YouTube algorithm and fun
fact but over 50 of the people who watch
our videos haven't taken the time to
subscribe if that is you do me a big
favor and subscribe right now and hit
that notification Bell to turn on all
notifications that way you will know
when the next demon saver video drops
and I promise you a new one is coming
very soon hunting Goose origin story
does get a double page spread in the
manga specifically in chapter 126 but
the backstory is then expanded upon in
the extra material ever since he was
just a child hunting who had been a
compulsive liar and he constantly made
up excuses for doing horrible things in
his own mind he was always a victim of
Cruelty and Injustice and anyone who got
in his way was a terrible bully and a
villain he had an insane victim complex
we're talking like Twitter activist
level of victim complex and he twisted
facts and made up story stories in order
to present himself as a poor innocent
man who has been unjustly wronged by
everyone but despite thinking of himself
as a victim huntegu was actually a
ruthless criminal who did many terrible
things throughout his life he stole from
people and he also murdered people in
towns and cities across Japan if he was
ever suspected of wrongdoing and
questioned about it he would outright
deny any wrongdoing and he would
endlessly profess his innocence on one
occasion he would go so far as to claim
that he was not responsible for his own
actions because his hands were to blame
implying that he had no control over
them he was a good guy but his hands
acted on their own and forced him to do
bad things there is some question about
whether hantegu was just making up
excuses because he was a cruel
narcissist who thought he had the right
to do whatever he pleased no matter how
many people got hurt or whether he was
mentally ill and genuinely believed that
he wasn't the one doing these terrible
things in my opinion it is more likely
that he was just a narcissist who
believed that everything in the world
was his for the taking and that anyone
who got in his way deserved to die after
all if the entire world revolves around
him as every narcissist thinks it does
and if he believes that he is the main
protagonist of the story as every
narcissist certainly does then according
to his perspective only a villain would
dare to get in the way of the
protagonist and his desires I think this
option is more likely because I find it
hard to believe that muzon would have
recruited someone who was completely
mentally unhinged as one of his upper
moons someone who is totally mentally
unstable would not be a very dependable
servant and he would be harder to
control because he was a notorious and
violent criminal hauntengu would often
change his name in other aspects of his
identity in order to avoid being caught
by the authorities this again suggests
that he knew that what he was doing was
wrong and that he took premeditated
action in order to stay one step ahead
of the law according to the fan book he
apparently married and had children
multiple times but whenever he was
confronted about his deceptive nature he
would become enraged and game end his
own family he would then repeat the same
cycle over and over again Han Tengu was
apparently 87 years old when he became a
demon and this happened after he was
finally captured by a magistrate and
sentenced to death for his crimes even
then huntegu continued to plead his
innocence over and over again despite
the fact that he was 100 percent guilty
to be fair it does seem like hunting
might have started to at least partially
believe his own lies because he was just
so adamant in professing his innocence
despite everyone knowing that he was
guilty he himself included one day as
huntengu sat in jail awaiting his
execution he was approached by muza the
progenitor of the Demons offered to save
huntengu's Life by turning him into a
demon and being a narcissist who only
cares about his own self-preservation
hantegu accepted the offer after
becoming a demon huntengu escaped
captivity and he immediately went to get
revenge on the magistrate who condemned
him to death Hunt angu killed the
magistrate but the Magistrate's dying
words would haunt the demon for a long
time to come the magistrate said that
even though he has escaped for now
hunting whose past sins will catch up to
him eventually and he will be punished
no matter how hard he tries to escape
his fate in the end no matter how long
it takes his Day of Reckoning will
arrive hunting was a demon for about 200
years prior to the beginning of the main
Demon Slayer story and over that time he
developed one of the trickiest and most
powerful Blood Demon arts in the entire
story Han Tengu is able to create
multiple younger clones of himself and
each of these clones represents a
powerful emotion that huntengu possesses
the Clones are all different they have
different abilities and personalities
and they even look different which can
be quite confusing for anyone trying to
fight huntengu the Clones all have kanji
on their tongues which identify the
emotion that they represent and hantegu
can either control them or allow them to
act on their own this Blood Demon art
comes into effect once someone cuts off
the head of the form that huntegu
normally uses the head and the body will
then each transform into two separate
clones and if these two clones are
relieved of their heads they will just
multiply again and turn into four
separate clones this pattern will repeat
a itself again and again but if more
than four clones are created the
individual clones will then become
weaker the Clones cannot be killed even
if you behead them with a nitrogen blade
which makes them incredibly difficult to
fight that said injuring the tongues of
the Clones is a good strategy in battle
it won't kill them but it will slow down
their ability to regenerate finally even
after his cones are activated huntengu
still has a main body which can be
killed if you can find it speaking of
the main body Han Tengu also has the
ability to change his size at will and
so he can make his main body very small
I'm talking the size of a mouse he can
then hide that body in a place that you
normally wouldn't even think to look
because you don't expect a demon to be
so small if that wasn't enough huntegu
has the ability to hide his demonic
presence which along with his ability to
become small makes him incredibly
stealthy and difficult to pin down we
eventually learned that hunting ability
to create multiple clones was developed
progressively over time many times
throughout his life hauntengu had been
cornered and put into a very difficult
life or death situation in these
situations hunting who would use his
blood demon art to divide and to
manifest a strong emotion to protect
himself there are six of these emotions
that we get to meet on top of huntengu's
main body but instead of just listing
them out here let's talk about them as
they appear in the big battle against
huntegu that takes place during the
swordsmith village Arc and quick warning
from this point on I will be spoiling
what happens to huntagoo in the
swordsmith village Arc so please proceed
with caution you have been warned so
after the upper Moon meeting both
hantegu and Yoko are sent out to the
swordsmith Village to essentially
destroy it and kill everyone there
thereby depriving the demon sire core of
their critically important ability to
produce nichidin blades hunting seen
crawling on the roof of one of the
buildings in the middle of the night he
knows that muzan is angry and he and
Yoko have to hurry and prove their
usefulness to their Master right away as
muichiro and tanjiro are talking while
nezuka sleeps Han Tango just randomly
crawls into their room huntengu is so
good at hiding his presence that the
demon Slayers didn't even realize he was
there until they saw him with their own
eyes shocked muichiro and tanjiro both
attack huntengu but surprisingly he only
seems to be dodging and he screams at
them to stop being mean to him
eventually muichiro succeeds in taking
off the Demon's head but instead of
dying hunting who splits into two
different parts the head grows another
body and the original body grows on
other head the two demons look
completely different than hantangu did
they look younger and stronger and they
now use completely different names their
names are sekido the manifestation of
huntingus anger and karaku the
manifestation of hantangu's idleness or
relaxation genya then shows up and in
time both demons are beheaded but again
instead of dying the demon split once
more creating four separate clones the
two new demons are named aizitsu the
manifestation of sorrow and urogi the
manifestation of Joel and these guys are
now also on the battlefield along with
sekido and karaku tanjiro warns the
others that this demon can't be defeated
in a conventional way hantegu seems to
actually want them to attack him and
take off his head because that makes him
multiply and get even stronger meanwhile
ouijito tries to rush back to rejoin the
fight but on his way back he encounters
upper Moon 5 Yoko and so his Focus turns
to that fight instead tanjiro now knows
that there are four main demons and each
one has a different word on its tongue
Joy anger sorrow and pleasure tanjiro
also realizes that if he can damage the
tongues of these demons they will then
regenerate more slowly during the fight
nezuko uses her blood demon art to set
tanjiro's sword on fire and the
resulting heat along with nezuko's blood
turns tanjiro's blade red this is
actually a huge deal because bright red
nitrogen blades can burn demons on a
cellular level the strongest Demon
Slayer in history yorichi tsugikuni
possessed a Black Blade just like
tanjiro but it would turn bright red in
battle with his burning red blade
tanjiro uses hinokami kagura San Halo
dragon head dance to decapitate three of
the four demon clones at the same time
genya is able to take the head of the
fourth one but even though the
Regeneration of the Demons has slowed
down they are still not dying and that's
when tanjiro realizes that there must be
a fifth demon out there somewhere a
fifth body that must be destroyed in
order for huntengu to be defeated thanks
to tanjiro's sensitive nose genya is
able to locate the main body this body
looks like the original hunting goo but
it is Tiny about the size of a mouse
huntengu is using his small size to hide
while the Clones do his Dirty Work Kenya
and tanjiro attempt to kill the tiny
demon but then a new demon shows up to
protect the miniature huntengu this
sixth demon is actually the other four
demons coming together to create a new
identity zohakuten the manifestation of
huntengu's hatred as I said earlier
hauntengu has the ability to get
stronger whenever he becomes cornered
and is in fear for his life and the more
pressure he is feeling the stronger he
becomes the sixth demon hatred is the
ultimate embodiment of that strength the
new demon is way stronger than the other
ones and he immediately gains an
advantage over time
in battle thankfully that is when the
love hashira mitsuri comes to the rescue
she uses her incredible flexibility and
Agility along with the thin and flexible
nature of her sword to counter the
demons overpowered attacks she is nearly
killed at one point after absorbing A
Massive Attack directly but her
superhuman muscle density allows her to
survive the attack and she is then
pulled to safety by tanjiro Kenya and
nezuko mitsuri gets back into the battle
raises her heart rate and manages to
manifest the Demon Slayer Mark now
faster and stronger than ever before
mitsuri is able to buy the others time
to track down huntengu's real body a
struggle ensues as hunting who increases
the size of his body and manages to
fight back but due to all the energy
that the other demons have used up he is
getting weaker and weaker desperate to
regain his strength hunting who tries to
find humans to devour but after
manages to take huntengu's head using
hinokamikagura dancing flash a form that
combines hinokami kagura with zenitu's
Thunderclap and Flash technique but
huntengu still doesn't die for some
reason his headless body continues to
move in an attempt to reach the humans
tanjiro then realizes that even this was
not the real body this body is yet
another demon clone urami the
manifestation of Han tengu's resentment
so for those keeping track that is now
Six Demon clones on top of the real body
for a total of seven demon forms
huntegu's real body has taken on a
miniature form and it is actually hiding
inside the heart of urami the sun is
just about to rise and tanjiro has to
make an incredibly hard decision should
he save his sister Nancy from the Sun or
should he save the innocent humans from
huntengu in the end tanjiro decides to
perform his duty as a Demon Slayer and
to save the innocent humans that Han
Tengu was targeting he cuts down both
urami and huntengu's real body just as
the sun rises huntengu is dead but what
happened to nezuko was she destroyed by
the sun to find out the truth about
nezuku's unique demon powers and why she
is the chosen demon don't ignore my
fullness video link in the description
and on screen if you guys enjoyed this
demonstrator video and you want to see
more in the future don't forget to leave
that like and if you're one of the over
50 of people who watch our videos but
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a big favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications